so in the year 2011 I saw the Smurfs and
this happened in my review it's so bad
it's so freakin bad this movie is just I
hate it and so today I saw the sequel
let's talk about it the Smurfs 2 is
directed by Raja Gosnell the man behind
home alone 3 and never been kissed Big
Momma's House scooby-doo scooby-doo 2
monsters unleashed yours mine and ours
Beverly Hills Chihuahua and the Smurfs
in this film Smurfette voiced by Katy
Perry is kidnapped by Gargamel played by
Hank Azaria because he needs Smurf
essence to be able to use his magic
because apparently his magical powers
are running out he wants to rule the
world he's now a famous celebrity who
performs magician shows in front of
humongous crowds who view him as like
essentially God because he can literally
wield magic the same time we have Neil
Patrick Harris and his family back again
and Brendan Gleeson as his stepfather
and they didn't have the best childhood
together because he's no he's a
stepfather and that doesn't always work
out and they have to learn to be friends
again while a few other Smurfs go out to
try to rescue Smurfette who is now a
damsel in distress at the hands of
Gargamel now in my original review for
the Smurfs I said this the movie is so
bad it's not gonna make any money at all
it's opening with Crazy Stupid Love and
cowboys and Aliens and I admit that I
was completely wrong that movie actually
made 563 million dollars worldwide
yes a half a billion dollars was made by
the Smurfs Wow
and naturally now we have a sequel how
was it look I'm not gonna sugarcoat this
okay this is not a movie that's for me
and I know that I go into this movie and
I know that more than likely I'm
probably not gonna enjoy it but I'm
willing to give it a chance as I do with
all movies that's why I went to the film
every time I go to a screening and sit
down in front of the movie screen I'm
giving the film a chance that's how I
give it a chance and like I said I am
NOT gonna sugarcoat this this movie
isn't for me this is a movie made for
very young children and very young
children will probably enjoy it it's
filled with slapstick humor it's filled
with fart jokes and spit jokes and lots
and lots of cuss words that are replaced
with the words Smurfs constantly and
that's really it
so if you're gonna bring your kids to
this movie or someone else's kids don't
steal other people's kids that's bad I
mean if you're babysitting someone
that's what I meant
they'll probably enjoy it I went with my
friend and his two daughters really
enjoyed the film that's not an excuse
for a crappy movie because the Smurfs 2
is a very crappy movie just like the
first one this movie is littered with
product placement this comes from
Columbia Pictures which is owned by Sony
every single product in this movie is a
Sony product the first half of the movie
is nothing but Gargamel looking at
tablets from Sony and thinking wow what
is this magical contraption called a
tablet oh I can swipe on it like he
literally looks at it holds it goes oh I
swipe I like the swiping motion it's
literally a commercial for Sony tablets
it's absurd one of the characters in
this movie gets turned into a duck and
some humans walk by this duck and you're
like wow what's going on there the dog
looks at them and goes global warming
buy a Prius wow these movies are made to
sell stuff ok and that's really what it
is it's a merchandising effort they're
not made with any real talent except for
the animation the animation is great
whoever did the animation for this movie
good job because they're really good at
it and that's really the only good thing
I can say about this movie Bank Azaria
is not funny at all as Gargamel he's a
big bumbling guy who makes weird faces
with buck teeth and he falls down a lot
that's essentially the humor of his
character his whole plan is so idiotic
he wants to rule the world by creating
Smurf essence and getting more power to
use his magic and everything but he's
already essentially a God on earth to
humans like when he walks into a mutant
park everyone just looks at him like oh
my god it's Gargamel oh you're so
amazing he's already a God he has actual
magic powers in a wand that he can use
he doesn't need anything else to rule
the world he can rule the world any
second he wants to except he wants to
create a huge diabolical plan because
he's running out of essence which means
he won't be able to do his magic I get
it he doesn't need some big diabolical
plan he has the ability to generate
whatever he wants he can rule the world
in an instant the whole story with Neil
Patrick Harris and Brendan Gleeson for
some reason is in this movie is there to
teach some kids a lesson and I can
understand that it's supposed to be
there and why it's there it just it's
not
for me okay the Smurfs - is not a film
made for me the Smurfs is definitely for
kids adults may find it mildly enjoyable
they might not hate themselves as they
watch it but i sat there just thinking
this movie is made to sell things I mean
every two seconds of this movie is a
product placement of some kind I just
can't stand the idiotic acting in the
slapstick humor it's also annoyingly
stupid and the voice acting oh my gosh
one of the Smurfs is named vanity and he
basically spends the entire movie
looking at himself in mirrors and making
jokes about himself and it literally
wasn't funny the first time but the rest
of the movie is him looking at a mirror
and going you are sexy and making a joke
about how good-looking he is the cat
falls down a lot the cat gets wet a lot
you know it's just it's all just the
same things over and over and I can't
really stand it I didn't like the Smurfs
- at all I'm not gonna give this film a
higher grade simply because it's not for
my demographic I do like children's
films if they're made well and I can
tell you that if I had kids right now
and I had the choice to show them Toy
Story or The Smurfs
there's no choice at all it's Toy Story
because it's a great film that actually
can teach kids a little bit not just
about filmmaking but about relationships
and friendships The Smurfs is one of
those movies that is just entertainment
for children with a couple good moral
lessons in there and I'm not gonna give
the film a good grade simply because I'm
an adult
it's filled with the newest pop songs to
be able to sell a cool pop song album
and it's just I just don't like it it
might be a slight improvement over the
first one simply because I didn't feel
like walking out as soon as I feel like
walking out of the first one that's
pretty much the best compliment that I
can give the Smurfs - it's not for me
and I don't think it's a good film for
kids you know they'll sit there and not
be bored but I don't really think it's
gonna teach them anything important or
good or I'm gonna get this soon I'm
gonna get the Smurfs - Adi - you know it
might be a slight improvement over the
first one I can't quite give it an F you
know like it's not one of those movies
where I was just like no it was more
like which isn't as bad as an F I guess
so thanks very much for watching guys if
you see the phone let me know what you
thought of it but don't see it just my
advice thanks very much guys and if you
like this you can click right here and
get stuck
nice
[Music]